whether you're religious or not you
should thank god there's no Fox News in
Germany this is Jay Rosen I teach
journalism at New York University he's a
leading media critic in the u.s. but he
came to Germany to compare how the
American and German media systems
operate it turns out according to Rosen
one of Germany's biggest advantages is
what it doesn't have Fox News Brussels
there you see him walking across the
stage in the United States you can have
some crazy made-up story that has
absolutely no factual basis and is
essentially a conspiracy theory just
cooked up obscure corners of the extreme
right wing and it can go from there to
the White House literally to the White
House to the to the words of the
president in 24 hours there is a
partisan press in Germany but Rosen says
a key difference between the two
countries is the strength of German
public broadcast would not deny in fact
Germany spends more than $100 per person
per year on public broadcaster's the
u.s. a little more than two dollars the
fact that we don't have public media
that is funded securely the way the BBC
is in the UK and the way the public
broadcasting is here with the license
fee is a major weakness of American
democracy but journalists in both
countries are having the same debate how
best to cover populist and provocative
politicians one example here is the
far-right alternative or Germany or AFD
party whose politicians have repeatedly
broken the taboos of German politics we
can't ignore the AFT it's part of German
politics right which is exactly what
journalists in the u.s. say we can't
ignore him he's the president but
they're aware that by covering for
example stunts that the AFD is famous
for wild statements you know like that
kind of a statement is is made to
generate news coverage and outrage
people so we have to cover it but by
covering it aren't we sort of
cooperating with this movement and in
the u.s. that move
of course Donald Trump fake news fake
news Russia is fake news the way
journalists cover President Trump is
something Rosen has been following
closely I wouldn't say I'm I'm following
it closely I would say I'm following it
obsessively he says the challenge for
journalists is that President Trump
breaks all the norms when it comes to
how a president is supposed to behave
that put reporters in unfamiliar terrain
our press wants to hang on to its
practices when they have proven
themselves to be broken it's not like
you can call a halt to the news engines
and say we'll be back in and in three
months when we fix this you have to keep
operating so what's the best way to deal
with the president who lies attacks
journalists and throws out the rulebook
there's no easy answer but Rosen has a
radical suggestion American journalists
should suspend normal relations with the
trunk government Rosen says it's time to
treat President Trump like a rogue state
not covering his rallies live is
suspending normal relations sending
interns to the briefing room instead of
your star reporters Sarah Huckabee
Sanders can't hate on them the way that
she does that would be breaking normal
relations now participating in
background briefings where Trump
government people get to talk without
their names being used would be a small
way of suspending normal relations Rosen
doesn't claim to have all the answers
but Rosen says the important thing is
for journalists to start rethinking the
habits that we've created for ourselves
because as Rosen says this is not a
normal presidency you can't cover it
like one